Văn phòng chính phủ vừa ra thùng báo năm 2018, nhiều cái lượng của phỏ thu tụt
lấy thành lòng yêu cầu đầy nhang 2 dự án cơ sở 2 bình viện hiểu nghị viết đức và bệnh mai
bảo đam ẩn thành trước ngày 2018 tháng 15 năm 2020.
Hịt khó lượng thí công đặt khoảng 70% viết đức và tâm 70% viết đức
và tâm 70% bệnh mai như nhiều hàng mục trọng, nhân lực chỉ đặt 2018 đến 2018 viết
Mỹ vấn trăm yêu cầu, bương mắc về dự tóan, đưa trình thiết kế, lên thông vấn mềm,
một sâm thiết bị quy trình phòng trái chữa trái và nhân sự chưa sự lý rất điểm, một số thiết bị đã lỗi thời,
hương học, phó thu tụt lưu cầu bộ ít tế chủ trị hoàn thành phy dự sự tóan thiết kế bản vẽ trước ngày 2018
ký phố lục đu trình hợp đồng Ngài Sau phê dựa.
Hòan tất, người hồ xương hiện thu phòng trái chữa trái đến bộ công an trước ngày 2018, các bấn đề khác phải dài quyết rất điểm.
Bộ xe dự, bộ công an, bộ quốc phòng, bộ tài chính, uống bán nhân dân tính liên bình và các nhà thầu phối hợp vi động một lực,
hương sẫn cơ chi tài chính bảo đàn tính độ và chất lực.